es ist wohl so relativ oft gibt es einen
schlimmen ausbruch der sonne einen
sonnen hurrikan ein sondern ausbruch und
das wurde jetzt berechnet würde das
gesamte stromnetz der erde ernsthaft
beschädigen und zwar so schlimm dass der
wiederaufbau und das ist hier die einzig
passende bezeichnung vier bis zehn jahre
dauern würde schaden laut dem
versicherer lloyds 2,6 millionen dollar
und das wären die folgen eines schwachen
sturms wie wahrscheinlich ist ein
solcher sturm was passiert bei einem
sonnen hurrikan der viel schlimmer ist
jetzt sind klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen das event war so ein
schwacher sonnenstürme 859 beobachtete
der britische astronom richard kärnten
einen ausserordentlichen strahlung und
teilchen ausbruch auf der sonne
telegrafen leitung hier auf der erde
sprühten im anschluss funken und
nordlichter waren auf kuba jamaika unter
weit zu sehen eine solche sonneneruption
würde heute aber einen deutlich höheren
schaden anrichten und das stromnetz
würde weltweit stark beschädigt werden
die folgen wären dramatisch und die
kosten lägen bei den genannten 2,6
billionen dollar
einen vorgeschmack lieferten die
sonnenstürme 1989 und 2003 damals fiel
der strom im kanadischen werk aus die
gps-signale wurden so stark gestört dass
flugzeuge sich nicht mehr danach
orientieren konnten und 1 600 millionen
dollar satellit wurde zerstört in den
usa hat der kongress 2015 deshalb einen
aktionsplan zum weltraumwetter
beschlossen um die folgen eines solchen
sturz abzuwenden doch bisher laufen
diese pläne ins leere weil man einfach
nicht weiß wie man sich vor solchen
sonnenstürmen schützen sollen bzw
einen es einen massiven umbau von allen
radverbindung und vor allem des
stromnetzes in den usa bedeuten würde
dazu gibt es aber noch keinerlei
anstalten und in europa wird einfach gar
nichts getan und die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass uns demnächst ein solcher sturm
trifft ist mit 10 sogar relativ groß wie
drei lief vom forschungsunternehmen
protective science im kalifornischen san
diego hat dazu die daten vergangener
sonneneruptionen ausgewertet und ist zu
diesem ergebnis gekommen
aber auch ein massiver sonnen hurrikan
ist demnach gar nicht so
unwahrscheinlich fuss anja physiker an
der nato
der university in japan und sein team
hat 2012 in drei jahresringen massiv
erhöhte werte von kohlenstoff 14 c14
gefunden die auf eine sehr große
sonneneruptionen einen sonnen hurrikan
schließen lassen das war in den jahren
774 und 775 also vom märz 1000 jahren
damals gab es noch keine kabel keine
satelliten und so weiter die
auswirkungen dürften minimal gewesen
sein und jetzt haben manas wie lehm und
erblüht von der amerikanischen harvard
university in einer aktuellen
forschungsarbeit 145000 sonnenähnliche
sterne angesehen sie haben die daten des
kepler weltraumteleskops analysiert und
dort bei den untersuchten sterne
nachgesehen wie oft solche super
ausbrüche solche superflex stattfinden
und ihre ergebnisse sind ernüchternd
alle 2000 jahre finden sie im
durchschnitt stadt statistisch haben wir
also noch zeit aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit für einen solchen
sonnen hurrikan ist da und steigt stetig
und bisher gibt es keine einzige idee
was wir dagegen tun können
die folgen wären dramatisch die gesamte
weltwirtschaft würde nahezu zum erliegen
kommt die schäden wären im zweistelligen
millionenbereich es wäre wirklich
wirklich schlimm aber lob und linken
haben eine idee ein riesiger draht ring
zwischen erde und sonne
er wird vom strom durchflossen und lenkt
die teilchen und die strahlung ab
gewicht 100.000 tonnen kosten rund 100
milliarden dollar
aber ist so ein großes projekt überhaupt
möglich es wäre quasi unsere erste alien
mega struktur und es ist möglich so viel
hat nämlich die internationale
raumstation
alles in allem gekostet wenn ich sogar
mehr es ist also möglich aber ich
fürchte dass wir vielleicht noch den
einen oder anderen sonnensturm hier auf
der erde erleben müssen bis die
menschheit hier aktiv wird wenn es neues
zum thema gibt dann erfahrt ihr es
natürlich hier drückt mir dafür hier ein
aber aufs auge und vergesse nicht den
genau auf die glocke denn wir dann
verpasst ihr nämlich kein video hier
geht es weiter mit alien mega struktur
aufgeklärt dafür auf das video klicken
und ansonsten bis dann begann